[Music]
on this Thursday night the U.S has maxed
out on its debt the possible
repercussions for America and the world
the debt limit poses significant risks
plus recession projections in Canada how
long it might last and its severity
after Alec Baldwin will be charged in
that fatal shooting on a film set his
potential prison sentence
calling it quips for me it's time why
one of the world's few female leaders is
leading her Legacy of leadership and of
course plowey McLeod face made the grade
so did control salt delete Darth blader
the punny named Edmonton dug up for its
snowplows
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with an eye on the economy
both here in Canada and in the U.S the
American government which has an
astonishing amount of debt has hit the
limit of what it can borrow it is quite
the Milestone the US owes a record 31.4
trillion dollars that's the so-called
debt ceiling to continue paying the
country's bills lawmakers must raise
that ceiling even higher so the U.S
government can borrow more money and
avoid a default and because the U.S is
the world's largest economy defaulting
would destabilize not just the U.S but
the entire global economy including
Canada avoiding that is going to involve
an intense political fight our coverage
tonight begins with Jackson prosco in
Washington
as the global economy Teeters on the
brink of recession American lawmakers
may push it Over the Edge by failing to
raise the limit on how much money the
U.S government can borrow what's known
as the debt ceiling if it actually isn't
raised that's extremely concerning uh
that would mean that the U.S government
cannot pay for all of the spending that
Congress has required it to pay for the
U.S already faces a staggering 31
trillion dollar debt a figure that has
risen under both Democrats and
Republicans the two parties usually
agree to raise the borrowing limit
they've done it more than 90 times
before this time Republicans refuse to
cooperate they're demanding deep
spending cuts while Democrats reject any
concessions find the compromise and find
the common sense compromise that puts us
back onto a balanced budget the clock is
now ticking on this unprecedented debt
default if it happens the U.S government
will be unable to pay for programs like
Social Security and unable to pay
salaries to millions of federal workers
the risks could spread worldwide because
the U.S will also be unable to make
payments on the trillions of dollars in
debt that are held by Foreign Nations
that would deliver a serious blow to the
U.S credit rating it could drive soaring
interest rates even higher a deep
recession would all but certainly follow
that's going to have
notable economic effects put that
alongside what I think would be a
significant stock market correction the
last time the U.S came close to default
was in 2011 when fear alone was enough
to drive down the U.S credit rating and
the markets before a deal was reached
the lessons from that near Miss may be
the best hope for ending this new round
of political brinksmanship by convincing
lawmakers that the cost of not borrowing
more is simply too high
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
that uncertainty in the U.S is just one
factor putting pressure on Canada's
economy a recent Bank of Canada's survey
found two-thirds of businesses and 70
percent of consumers think a recession
is likely in the next 12 months that
doesn't mean it will happen of course
and there are bright spots such as low
unemployment and gaviola has a reality
check on recession fears in Canada
show most Canadians think we're either
already in a recession or that there's
one right around the corner the next
couple of years are going to be pretty
rough for the economy but are we all
clear on what exactly that means
recessions are a significant widespread
and prolonged downturn in economic
activity typically defined as at least
two consecutive quarters of negative
economic growth most economists see a
recession in the cards this year but
they have different ideas about when it
will start and how long it will last our
research is showing 75 chance of
recession in the next 12 months we will
be in a recession starting in the first
half of 2023 High inflation Rising
interest rates and household debt levels
many call concerning are all factors so
are things happening beyond our borders
the war in Ukraine Europe's energy
crisis and the slowing of major
economies including the us but most
experts see a recession coming that as
recessions go go won't be the worst it's
going to be relatively mild compared to
historical standards there's also a
psychological aspect because recessions
can be self-fulfilling prophecies if
enough people worry about a recession
that pull back in spending and activity
can push economic growth into the red it
affects people's behavior in terms of
their spending patterns investment
patterns say when it comes to buying a
new home there are some bright spots
that Torrid pace of inflation has cooled
and our labor market is strong with
unemployment near record lows there's
enough job vacancies in the economy that
the pain of a recession or a typical
recession really not be felt this time
at all recession don't have to be scary
recession don't have to be like the one
that we experience in the financial
crisis in 2008 all the kovic pandemic in
2020. Canadians can keep this in mind as
they brace for yet another recession and
gaviola Global News Toronto some big
news in Hollywood actor Alec Baldwin
could face 18 months in jail he and a
weapons specialist from a movie set will
be charged with involuntary manslaughter
in the death of a cinematographer Helena
Hutchins was shot with a live round from
a prop gun in 2021 on the set of the
movie rust while Baldwin was rehearsing
a scene the district attorney says well
there was no intention to cause death
there was a lack of safety on the set
and actors shouldn't get a free pass
Heather urich's West reports
the fact that Alec Baldwin was holding
the gun that ultimately killed
cinematographer Helena Hutchins has
never been in question the 2021 shooting
death that took place on set during
rehearsal for the movie rust was
accidental involving a prop gun but more
than a year later investigators have
determined the 42 year old's death was
also criminal and three people including
the actor have been charged news of the
charges was posted on the New Mexico
District Attorney's Office Facebook page
after a thorough review of the evidence
and the laws of the state of New Mexico
I have determined that there is
sufficient evidence to file criminal
charges Mary karmic altwise said the
charges all relate to negligence nothing
intentional they're they are not trying
to show that any part of this wasn't
accidental they were just trying to show
that they were not exercising caution
and Care in how they handled the gun
Alec Baldwin and Hannah Gutierrez read
the armorer on set have each been
charged with two counts of involuntary
manslaughter well assistant director
David Halls pled guilty to a lesser
charge of negligent use of a deadly
weapon if any one of these three people
had done their job said special
prosecutor Andrea Reeb Alina Hutchins
would be alive today
Hutchins family welcomed the
announcement while Baldwin's attorney
said the charges represent a terrible
miscarriage of Justice I was a bit
surprised I thought the armor would be
charged but not Alec Baldwin himself
because according to reports he was told
that the gun was cold meaning there were
no live bullets in it live ammunition is
not allowed onto Canadian film sets but
serious and even fatal accidents happen
every year Hutchinson's death has placed
a spotlight on the dangerous still
present within the industry and the Need
For Change Heather your ex West Global
News
foreign
that I will not be seeking re-election
she had to compose herself to get those
words out New Zealand's prime minister
Jacinda ardern surprised everyone
yesterday with her news but after almost
six challenging years in office she has
said she's run out of steam
I know what this job takes and I know
that I no longer have enough in the tank
to do it justice
it's that simple
our Dern was 37 when she became leader
of New Zealand's labor party she easily
won two elections but she says one of
the lessons of leadership is knowing
when to leave Eric Sorensen reports on
her reasons and the reaction and let's
get as leader of a small far away island
nation Jacinda ardern's impact reached
far beyond the Jacinda Mania that swept
New Zealand
women on the world stage is not new but
women in positions of Power are still in
the minority and ardern brought a
compassionate leadership that is rare as
when a gunman in New Zealand slaughtered
Muslims during Friday prayers this is
one of New Zealand's Darkest Days ardern
decry the white supremacy behind the
attack but it was her heartfelt Sympathy
for the Muslim Community that stood out
most they have chosen to make New
Zealand their home in it is their home
they are us ardern's feelings were
unguarded and genuine and yet she was
decisive in what should happen next I
can tell you one thing right now our gun
laws will change and they did a
nationwide ban on the most deadly guns
ardern always seemed natural whether
meeting the public or responding to an
earthquake the moment it happened quite
a decent Shake here but if you see
things moving behind me and her reasons
now for leaving seem just as natural and
candid I am human
politicians are human
we give all that we can for as long as
we can
and then it's time
our Dern was one of the first world
leaders to give birth while in office
she seen as a stalwart for Progressive
values and women's rights Canada's prime
minister among those who thanked her for
her empathetic compassionate leadership
Australia's prime minister too called
her empathy and insight powerful
leadership qualities that's really rare
and really powerful and something that
people are craving you know real
authenticity real vulnerability when New
Zealand's covid restrictions worked I
did a little dance but like everywhere
else vaccines lockdowns and mask
mandates became highly controversial and
as a woman ardern may have been a prime
target for some threats against her
requiring police response tripled in the
last three years I think the cumulative
challenges that we've faced as a team
and they have been extraordinary
has taken its toll even that admission
represents uncommon leadership qualities
it's incredibly admirable that she
speaks out about her emotional health
and that she's not scared
um by doing that she smashes stigma from
other people they also feel comfortable
in doing that a bit shocked actually
yeah I can't believe it new zealanders
are surprised ardern is stepping back
but she's only 42 and many hope she will
step forward again somewhere on the
world stage Eric Sorensen Global News
Germany's chancellor says his country
will only send battle tanks to Ukraine
if the U.S does the same speaking at the
Davos Summit Olaf Schulz said Germany
will continue to make decisions based on
Partnerships with other allies but will
not act alone Ukraine says it needs
hundreds of Tanks to fend off Russia's
Invasion Poland and Finland have
german-made leopard two tanks Ukraine
wants but Germany needs to give
permission for their re-export Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau has not
ruled out sending tanks to if Germany
approves the donation of military
vehicles it sold to Canada Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski is blunt he
says while the Free World thinks the
terrorist State kills Western defense
ministers will meet on Friday to discuss
future military commitments to Ukraine
over a million protesters took to the
streets and cities across France today
they're angry about the government's
plans to raise the retirement age from
62 to 64 years to qualify for a full
State Pension
Police use tear gas to hold back massive
crowds in Paris some protesters there
throwing fireworks many held signs
saying pensions and salaries need to
rise not the age of retirement Emmanuel
macron's government says the reforms are
necessary to keep the pension system
running the reforms have not yet been
approved in Parliament and Union say
they will keep fighting
at least three more deaths have been
attributed to political protests in Peru
as thousands of demonstrators from rural
areas descended on the nation's capital
protesters flooded the streets of Lima
to show support for ousted former
president Pedro Castillo he was arrested
last month and is being investigated on
charges of rebellion and conspiracy
weeks of clashes between demonstrators
and police have resulted in more than 40
deaths according to Human Rights Watch
demonstrators are calling for fresh
elections and demanding Castillo be
released from prison
the federal housing Minister gets
grilled coming up the opposition's
appetite for answers about why he hired
a food marketing firm
there are more questions about the
Judgment of a federal cabinet minister
last year housing and diversity Minister
Ahmed Husson faced controversy over a
133 thousand dollar Grant to an
organization whose senior consultant
posted anti-semitic comments on social
media now the minister has spent ninety
three thousand dollars in constituency
funds for public relations help promote
Communications firm that specializes in
marketing food Mackenzie gray is
following this from Ottawa Mackenzie
well Donna Ahmed Hussein is under Fire
yet again for contracts he's handed out
this time paying for communications help
from a firm that specializes in the food
industry it's usually chefs and foodie
bloggers that toronto-based Munch more
media work with but Ahmad Hussein didn't
take the cookie cutter approach when he
hired the company to work in his
constituency according to public
documents the ministers Toronto office
gave 14 different contracts between
January 2021 and September 2022 to have
much more media do PR work the bill over
ninety three thousand dollars which
represents 14 percent of Hussein's
entire constituency office budget for
that period so who is much more media
hippoteric is listed as the company's
only director and works out of this
condo in Pickering she told Global News
her work for Hussein included planning
and drafting Flyers that are mailed to
constituents as well as videos and
content creation strategies as for the
marketing agency's own content creation
it's limited their last Instagram post
is from 2018 and they only had one
follower on Twitter that's until they
deleted their account earlier this
afternoon
prior to getting the 14 contracts tarek
said she had no personal connection with
Hussein but she does have ties to one of
Hussein's former senior staffers
abdicare Ahmed worked as Hussein's
former director of policy in 2020 and is
listed alongside Tarik as a co-director
of a corporation called Empire of
goodness Ahmed describes it as a
non-profit organization where he serves
as a volunteer director Tarik didn't
disclose her relationship with Ahmed
until we questioned her about it but she
says it's independent of her work with
Hussein the opposition believes the
minister shouldn't have given the
contracts out obviously doesn't pass a
smell test is something that's
problematic should not be happening they
always seem to find a way to give these
contracts to people they're friends with
or people who their friends are friends
with Hussein declined an interview
request but a spokesperson for the
minister defended the contracts saying
members of parliament are permitted to
expense a Communications firm to carry
out ways of communicating information to
their constituents and who sends offices
correct there are no rules saying the
Minister of Housing can't hire a
community locations for him to work for
him even if that company's big promised
Donna is to make clients a Pioneer in
The Culinary scene
all right Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank
you
honoring hockey history ahead one of the
sports Living Legends receives a
HomeTown tribute
[Music]
British tennis great Andy Murray pulled
off one of the most incredible comebacks
in recent history at the Australian Open
while playing under grueling conditions
at one point Murray was down two sets to
his Australian opponent but fought back
to victory in a five-set thriller and
what makes part of Murray's Resurgence
so amazing are the injuries he's
overcome the three-time Grand Slam
Champion underwent surgery to replace
part of his hip with a metal cap in 2019
this match was the longest of his career
lasting five hours and 45 minutes
a living legend in the hockey world is
being honored with a life-size portrait
in his New Brunswick hometown
two three
Willie Orie is the first black hockey
player to be drafted into the NHL his
portrait is now part of the permanent
collection at fredericton's Beaver Brook
Art Gallery Arie lives in California now
he couldn't be at the unveiling the
portrait marks the 65th anniversary of
his NHL debut with the Boston Bruins in
1958.
what's so honey next the clever snowplow
names to keep an eye out for in Edmonton
[Music]
they play a critical role in cities
every winter and never really get the
recognition they deserve well that has
all changed for Edmonton's snow plows
the city asked the public to suggest
names for 15 of its snow clearing
machines and boy did they slide into
action it's happening in other cities
too from Darth blader to buzz ice clear
snow plows are getting new identities
and a Sarah Ryan reports adding some Joy
To The Long Winter
edmontonians got slick with naming our
City's snow plows this winter originally
we were going to name five plows but
based on the overwhelming response to
this with over 2100 entries we expanded
to the top 15. winning names include
blizzard of Oz Buzz ice clear control
salt delete Darth blader and the big
laplowski some local celebs skidded in
too amherstle snowy and Connor mcblade
it that's Edmonton
these contests have been taking the
country by storm from St John New
Brunswick to Mission BC pretty soon
every municipality might have a plowey
mcplow face but Hamilton gets points for
creativity its top spot went to Max
culminator named for Max Kerman the
proud hamiltonian from arkells here in
Edmonton residents hope the new Snow
Patrol will start its Tour of Duty soon
in a neighborhood near them it is like
getting over a tiny mountain in and out
of parking stalls I definitely have
learned to counter drift on these side
roads lately and have witnessed like a
few cards slide into one another so it's
obviously not great the snow drift on
the road are like higher than my tires
so you've got to be in the right rotten
it's a mess they need to get out and do
that final plowing the city of Edmonton
says with unseasonably warm January
weather it's been receiving a number of
phone calls and emails from frustrated
drivers complaining about streets like
these in front of their homes this is
definitely an area we're hearing a lot
about and we hear you
we know the residential areas are sloppy
the city continues to say it's too warm
and they're worried about making bigger
ruts and large windrows that was
something that we experienced last year
with a lot of negative feedback about
people losing their parking but they say
Mr plow and all his friends will be
coming to the rescue soon next week once
the temperatures drop we'll be grooming
residential neighborhoods
our driveway snowed in and if Mother
Nature doesn't cooperate
you know who to call hello I'm Mr plow
Sarah Ryan Global News Edmonton
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen born with a
winter name tonight's year in Canada is
Peterborough Ontario thanks for watching
I'll see you Saturday for the new
reality but
[Music]